[Music]
how familiar were you with the Menendez
amendment honestly not at all
I called my mom immediately I was like
hey I'm gonna do this Menendez brother
movie and she knew everything about the
case she immediately took the parents
side right and being a mom and the
script takes a much more sympathetic
side to the brothers we like had this
banter back and forth what do you think
we can attribute that fascination to I
think that this was one of the first
televised court cases ever right and
they were so overexposed they were too
wealthy attractive white rich white kids
who killed a Paris they were so
sensationalized and there was also
dislike strange and just unusual erotic
factor to the whole story she's our
mother she's supposed to protect us
random acts no Courtney Love plays her
mom's goodness yes kitty Menendez what
is she like unset and real a fan of hers
growing up and to be honest with you the
second I saw the breakdown of the movie
I saw Courtney's name I signed on to the
movie she's such a layered human being
she's she's so much more than what
people think that she is she has this
hyper intelligence about her she put so
much work into the craft of acting right
and you know I I think she's really in
this like rebrand of sorts right now and
she's just dedicated to her her
well-being and it shows she did my
podcasts she was the first episode of
the second season that aired this week
any questions that you asked her that
you were nervous to ask her that you
were surprised by her answers I opened
each episode with the spoken word right
and so I wrote this love letter to
Courtney Love write for the Courtney
Love bomb and I was nervous to read to
her and she loved this she got emotional
we both got emotional reading is what's
the biggest misconception about Courtney
that she's crazy you know seems like I
don't think that I don't yeah right I
mean I feel like Courtney Love has been
witch hunted for four years right uh
and look we're all crazy in
in one way another but I think that
she's like crazy in all the right ways
and that she's just I don't know her
work ethic is like something I've never
seen why didn't you say anything
uh-huh that said that he would kill me
if I told anyone
there's alleged claims of abuse I did
you want to I guess prepare for that I
listen to some podcasts honestly that
that deal with physical abuse and sexual
abuse I just studied the script you know
I mean the script that we have is is
pretty much all of the facts are pulled
straight from court transcripts you said
the movie is more sympathetic to the
brothers do you feel like the public
should have been more sympathetic to the
brothers or why are you guys depicting
it that way I just think their story
deserve to be heard more than it was I
think that we didn't know too much about
sexual abuse in the early 90s riddled
with extreme homophobia the fact that
even existed in a court system 20-some
years ago is so insane to think about
you know and I think that that really
for me once I found that part out about
this case that was really the driving
force and why I wanted to tell this
story I'm not sympathizing with the
murder of their parents but I think that
that what what is important is just to
look at the help that they probably
needed you know what I mean did you get
to talk to I didn't brother the dollar
oh I didn't that was like my first
instinct was oh I got to reach out I got
to go you know sit down and talk awhile
if you ever didn't get the chance to sit
down with Lyle what would you ask him oh
man I would want to get into his
childhood before anything else I would
want to ask him like really what he
remembers about his childhood and
honestly
[Music]